also jetzt kann ich denn da aber
so jetzt
in der Schweiz und über ganz
Mitteleuropa verteilt gibt es viele Gang
wir da skurriler man weiß praktisch
nicht drüber ich weiß nicht ich habe
keine Ahnung
warum und wenn dir Gang gebaut wurde
sind und will man nicht weiß geht zur
Hufe Vermutung und Theorie über das
Phänomen
theoretisch sie ist auch ganz abstrus
ist eine Gang geht so die wildes Stück
Geschichte
archäologischer Rätsel nachher versuchen
was ist mit deiner Gang auf sich hat und
stoßen die ganze vor der Wissenschaft
das ist definitiv
[Musik]
speziellen Gruppe auf Stolle Exkursion
nämlich mit der Macher von dem
Youtube-Kanal da Hangar 18b in ihrer
Freizeit produzieren die Jungs Videos
rund um Mystery Thema Eis Thema wo sie
immer wieder aufgeliefert geheimnisvolle
Gang unter dem Schweizer Boden ich
treffe mit ihnen mit dem Wald in der
Nähe von wenigen Kanton Bern da sind
Gruppenmitglieder 2 Tage stationiert
ausgrischen Equipment wenn Sie heute
stelle Ihnen wo Sie schon mal erkunde
zwei weitere folgen
dass es sich um ein Fuchsbau handelt
aber den ist einfach so ein 30 Meter
langer Gang unter dem Hügel wo man nicht
darüber weiß das ist schon komisch ich
meine wer hätte Vergangenheit gab und
wieso
die andere sind schon fleißiger Masse
und Filme für das neues Video
30 Meter 20 Zentimeter
Punkt
[Musik]
die gängigste Theorie sagen
das heißt mit nachher
wasserquelles wasserleiter oder auch
dass man sie als wasserspeichert
brauchte Gruppe von Youtube Channel
Hangar 18b aber die Theorie a also ich
persönlich reden
ich weiß es einfach nicht
ich glaube nicht dass das
ja ich sehe keinen Sinn mit einer stören
und das ist interessanter vielleicht
findet man heute
interessiert aus für Mythen und
Mysterien und UFOs und alles was halten
solche
Geschichte also das gab bis hin zu dass
ich da ein teleportiert
oder so und um das Ganze
auf der Exkursion ist die pensionierte
Gymnasiallehrerin Helen wieder ihres
Fachgebiet ist Geologie schon seit
Jahren untersucht sie die
unterschiedliche unterirdische
Gangsystem auch für sie macht die
Wassergang Theorie wenig Sinn
aus Sicherheit
also ich kann
nicht
Kultur wo die hier passen
immer wieder in regelmäßige Abstand
40 cm
oder weniger aber so einen Gang wurde
über 20 m lang ist da hat man dann also
rasch einmal 50 Tage oder den
winterbruch bis mit der Krankheit in der
Schweiz gibt's
Gang wovor haben dies weicher geworden
aber
es macht keinen Sinn da ins Wasser
Grundwasser ist 17 Meter tiefer runter
also
momentan
nur Wasserstelle oder aber mehr ich
werde es genauer wissen es sind diese
ganzen Deutschland Österreich und
Frankreich aber auch Italien über
England bis Schottland gefunden wurde
die Gang geht das sind aber meistens
noch
andere und sind häufiger als in der
Schweiz unterschiedlich finde im
Deutschen
raumstall im Französischen und
englischer um zu terra
befindet die Gang aber auch in lokalen
Marley erzähle
[Musik]
warum er am Mittelalter zum Zweck von
deiner Art Stall oder raus
krankschreiben
erstens sind oder dass es cool stetig
sie sind zum Beispiel symbolische Lage
aber für die tote Seeler wenn die
mittelalterliche Siedler sind oder sind
erwarte bis zu mir kriegt wiederum
andere meine
Worte sind oder
4 und letzte Theorie dass es einfach aus
versteckt die enthält ich kann auf der
Stelle Exkursion Talent gefragt was sie
denn meint sich als ich aber nicht
vorstellen dass die Gang aus versteckt
wurde sind als Versteck und als
Fluchtort sind sie umbruchbar sie sind
Faller ich meine sobald
natürlich verloren
drin
kannst du mich auch filmen
obwohl sie wirklich nur Operation aber
eigentlich nicht
aber
ich fühle mich halt wohl wieder mal
Überstunden
auch
es ist Faszination wo die 80-Jährige Art
liebt thailändisch im europäischen Raum
aber lang mit die einzige was Rätsel
möchte
es gibt
natürlich
so gegeneinander
viel wieder zurück entstanden sind
nämlich vor acht bis 25000
einer über ihre arbeiterkette aber
leider habe ich oft Interview Anfragen
keine Antwort bekommen
unserem Stollen
YouTube-Kanal Hangar 18b zurück waren
Talent der kuschtheorie eher skeptisch
gegenüber ist sind einzelne Gruppe für
die Erklärungen
[Musik]
das ist für viele Expertin und Experte
doch sehr unklar wie viele andere
Spekulationen auf dem Kanal für die
Jungs kann man auch die
wissenschaftlichen
am Schluss vor der Exkursion geben
und materialzustellen
aber was mich jetzt eigentlich am
meisten wundern nimmt ist was man von
offizieller sieht eigentlich zu deiner
Gang meint ich kontaktiere mehrere
Archäologische Institut für diverse Unis
und unterschiedliche Kantons Archäologie
zum offiziellen Seite mehr über die
unerklärliche Gang zu fahren doch
Rückmeldungen
weil entweder bekomme keine Antwort oder
sind einfach keine Informationen dazu
einzigstechnologie
ich erhoffner dass er vielleicht
Geheimnis verläuft
und das ist als einziger
nein Spaß natürlich
nur einiges mehr zu der Stelle verzählt
das ist die gibt aber das heißt sehr
nett im Kanton 40
Tieren wieso haben die einen ähm für das
Tiere braucht
oder wenn es wo mit dem Bau verbunden
ist holzkohlerestaurant
Methoden
ist es dann einfach im Detail sehr
schwierig und wissen sie das ist ja
jetzt relativ speziell aber wir haben
zum Beispiel nicht genau
sagen mir sammeln
im Schnitt 150 bis 200 Untersuchung pro
Jahr im Kanton Bern und da ist klar dass
viele Sachen einfach
werden
[Musik]
momentan
der aktuelle Stand des Irrtums ich es
sind quellstelle ja für dich
wieso sie baut oder sind wir acht bis
zehn verschiedene die erklären
wir Dimension flächenmäßig
das Wetter verifizieren
[Musik]
deiner Stelle nicht findet ist es
praktisch unmöglich zum siedatieren und
darum auch uninteressant für Archäologie
Einfachheit darum dass es Wasserstelle
sind ich triffe Nummer telen das mal ich
kann Stollen sondern wie ihre
vom Gespräch mit dem herbeiswil und dass
er auch keine Erklärung
und das ist viel weniger
wenn ich das weitergegeben
nicht verloren hat und vielleicht sogar
hilft es Geheimnis eines Tages lüften
je mehr ich möchte mit dem Thema
befassen desto mehr fasziniert mich ich
besuche nun weitere Stollen im Kanton
Thurgau aber auch da haben wir gemeint
auf Mini Afrika
oder erklären und genau darum aber auch
ganz viele so Theorie entstanden was ich
hasse sage
wieso wissen wir nicht aber welche
Mörder haben
was aber so wichtig ist ich glaube das
bleibt noch längeres Rätsel aber was
glaubst du wieso hat man dir
ohne Kommentar und für mehr so Videos
abonniere jetzt da den Kanal